let's get started
so with clean architecture the domain
and the application layer are at the
center of the design this is known as
the core now the domain contains
enterprise logic and types and the
application layer contains business
logic and types the difference being
that enterprise logic could be shared
across many systems whereas business
logic would only be typically used in
this application now rather than have
core depend on concerns such as data
access and infrastructure we invert
those dependencies so infrastructure and
presentation depend on core but core has
no dependencies this is achieved by
adding interfaces or abstractions into
core which are then implemented by their
outside layers so you can see with this
design all dependencies point inwards
and this results in an architecture and
design that is independent of frameworks
we don't need some framework to build
and maintain our solution its testable
and in fact it's really really easy to
test with everything inside of core we
can write unit tests for a hundred
percent of our logic and it's all logic
as I said it's business logic and
enterprise logic it's independent of the
UI right now we're using asp.net core
three front-end with angular but we can
switch that out and it's easy to do so
and that's because inside of core we
have well-defined view models and all of
our logic is encapsulated we haven't let
any of that logic creep into the
front-end it's independent of the
database right now we use in sequel
server we've switched it successfully to
Postgres later on we're gonna switch it
to cosmos TV probably back to Postgres
again and we can do that because we have
a wonderful abstraction in place and
finally it's independent of anything
external and with this design that's the
difference between an applications go in
the last three years and an application
are still going to be here in 20 years
now you can see with these layers
there's only three but think of this as
a starting point you can add more if you
need to add additional layers just
remember to keep those dependencies
flowing inwards let's take a look at a
couple of examples so when I first
started doing this talk in 2018 we were
using the Northwind traders sent
solution why you might ask well because
I still think Northwind traders is cool
and I wanted to share it with the world
and the good news is I wasn't wrong this
project has taken off it's now starred
by almost 3,000 people and forked by
almost 1000 people and that's amazing so
I wanted to take a moment to thank that
community thank you for your
contributions
thank you for your pull request thank
you for the tough questions thank you
for your support
it's amazing keep that up but based on
Northwind traders I've now built a clean
architecture template and with this
template I now have a very simple file
new project experience and that's what
it's all about right kiss keep it simple
so we're going to use this template
today and have a look at some of the
features that I've built into it and
then at the end I'll show you how to
install it and how to get started can't
actually see my mouse that's tricky
I'll work with it okay so you can see
here in our clean architecture template
we've got basically a sample application
now I started this off by going for a
new project with an angular asp.net core
solution and then built in a clean
architecture back-end with all the
features we've come to know and love
from from the Northwind traders solution
so you can see here we've got the domain
layer the application layer the
infrastructure layer and the web UI
layer in addition to that we've got a
bunch of tests so for domain and
application we've got unit tests and for
infrastructure and web UI we've got
integration tests
you know hopefully I get my mouse back
okay so the key points domain contains
enterprise-wide logic and types the
application contains business logic and
types remember enterprise can be shared
across many systems but the business
logic is specific to this application
infrastructure contains all external
concerns and that now includes
persistence presentation and
infrastructure depend on only on
application they don't depend on each
other and that way we ensure that these
components can be replaced with minimal
effort but just take a moment to think
about presentation infrastructure
relationship it's very easy to go ahead
and add in dependency to infrastructure
and then start using infrastructure
services for example in the web
front-end we might want to send an email
and it's easy enough to do in a
controller but then that's logic in the
front-end and we need to keep that logic
out of the front-end because it can't be
reused all right let's all look at the
domain layer so in the domain layer we
have entities value objects enumerations
logic and exceptions hey my mouse came
back that's so good I'm really pleased
about that
so the first thing that I want to point
out in the domain layer is to avoid
using data annotations so you can see
here we've kept this solution simple
because it's a file new project solution
we're going to be adding our own
entities but you can see nonetheless I
have a to-do item and I haven't used
data annotations and why is that
well I won't complete mine keep mine
domain model clean I want to keep data
annotations out of my domain model later
on when we look at infrastructure of
course we'll look at using fluent API
configuration which will help with our
and laughing but for now we'll keep it
clean one thing you can see there is
I've also got an auditable entity base
class on this so this solution is
jam-packed with examples auditable
entity is one of those just by attaching
that base class to this entity will
actually have a number of fields Auto
populated when Save Changes is fine
including the user ID who create
to date time their credit these are ID
who modified it and the date time that
was last modified so one of the key
points I'd like to make is using value
objects so I have a sample value object
in here and it's an ID account and you
might be thinking well ad accounts
pretty trivial why not just use a string
and that's because it's not a string
it's um it has a specific logic that's
associated with it and specific logic
that will have to write when we use it
for example it's often common when
you're using an ad account to grab the
domain part and to use that it's often
common to also grab the username part
and you also need to display it in its
normal format so this value object
actually encapsulates all of that you
can see it's got a factory which will
take in an account string split it up
into a domain and name and it will throw
an invalid exception if the format's not
supported and you might think well why
bother throw in that exception and it's
because it's a custom exception it's
something that we can understand ad
account invalid exception is much easier
to understand and index out of range
exception so you can see here it's
pretty simple it's just got a couple of
properties domain and name and we have
some unit tests associated with that
which make it really easy to understand
how it works so looking in here we've
got a test should have correct domain
and name and basically we take an
account string we use the factory method
to construct an account and then we
assert that those properties are correct
so you can see that it's quite easy to
use and it's going to be easy for new
developers to use as well they're not
going to think how do I work with this
ad account object it's a string what
logic do I have to write it's all built
into it so then we have a two string
method we check that it returns the
correct former we have an implicit
conversion method which basically can
take an ID account implicitly convert it
to a string it should be the correct
account string we have an explicit
conversion method where we can cast an
idea and their Cal string into an ID
account test those results and we've got
a quick test to ensure that if the
format's invalid such as it is here SSW
jason moe backslash that it throws that
exception
so this is really simple to use so you
just have to think about when you're
defining your entities and you're
utilizing primitive types is it really a
primitive type or is it something more
complicated is a postcode just an
integer or is it a complex system with
rules that are associated with it that
you're going to have to program into
your application and those rules which
couldn't start a period in many places
throughout your application because
there's not a central location so pretty
simple one thing to point out is that
behind the scenes here there is a value
object base class and that's basically
about equality so two value objects are
the same if they share the same value
what this does is get all of the values
associated with the value object and
compare them so that implementation
actually came from the Microsoft Docs so
you can learn more about it here okay
one point that I like to make and this
is a simple point it's just in your
entities make sure you that you
initialize all collections and also set
them to have a private set or just
remove the setter altogether it might
seem like a trivial thing but it really
helps and especially helps new
developers if you don't do that you'll
be writing logic such as order order
details and you'll check if order dot
order details equals null then order dot
order details equals a new collection
and you'll have that logic start to
appear all over the place wherever
you're dealing with order details by
doing it this way it's always
initialized it doesn't matter whether
you created a new order yourself or
whether it came back from energy
framework and new developers won't have
this problem they won't kind of run into
the issue and if they do try to
initialize it because it's got a private
setter they're going to see actually
that doesn't work I can't actually do
that that's not the way they do things
within these solution so we're actually
teaching our developers how to work with
this solution and how to fall into the
pit of success we make it easy to do the
right thing and hard for them to do the
wrong thing
one of the things that I've changed in
this solution is I've added a let's see
well that's the Northwind one in this
one
I've added an interface for I date/time
so previously I had that in a common
project as a cross-cutting concern but I
just thought why have it there why not
move it to the very center of the design
so that everywhere in the application
it's easy to add and we don't actually
have a common project that has to be a
dependency on every other project it's
just there it's ready to use and it's
implemented within an infrastructure so
that's it for the domain lawyer key
points I'd like to make there is avoid
using data annotations there's a better
way we can keep our entities clean use
value objects where appropriate just
think is it really a primitive type or
is it something more complex than that
initialize all collections and use
private setters create custom domain
exceptions because they're a lot easier
to debug and automatically track changes
using auditable entity we're going to
take another look at that at the
implementation once we get to the
infrastructure layer oh and avoid
dependency on the system clock with I
date/time and why would we want to do
that well because the system clock is an
is infrastructure it's an external
dependency and if we have logic that
depends on say something like date/time
dot now and that logic is only going to
run on a Tuesday we can only test that
effectively on a Tuesday we'll have to
have an if statement or something that
says hey is today Tuesday we can run
this unit test otherwise we'll wait so
by doing an I date time we can lock that
out and then we can make it to be
whatever we want it is so now let's have
a look at the application layer so in
the application layer we've got
interfaces so those are the abstractions
and interfaces that are going to be
implemented by the outside layers will
see those will have models view models
and details will have logic commands and
queries we're gonna look at that fella
data's and exceptions so first up I want
to introduce a concept I'm sure a lot of
you are familiar with it
CQRS the command query responsibility
segregation pattern
so with this we actually separate our
reads our queries from our rights our
commands and this can result in
maximizing performance scalability and
simplicity but for me it's all about the
simplicity and the first time I tried it
I was amazed at how simple I was making
able to make my system just by following
this pattern it's easy to add new
features when were following this
pattern because we can just add a new
query or command so generally a feature
is going to relate to one query and/or
one command and it's easy to maintain
because our changes only affect a single
command or query we try to encapsulate
everything that belongs to that command
or query into a single folder so that we
when we go to that folder everything
that we need to update that feature can
be changed in the one place we try to
minimize sharing between those commands
and queries so that we can avoid
breaking changes we do encourage code
reuse just not when it's a different
feature so if you like secure us your
log mediator perfect perfect partnership
so with mediator we can do some simple
things such as defining commands and
queries as requests so we use I request
and I request handler but after that our
application layer just becomes a series
of request response objects so
everything in our application layer is
either a command or query we define them
as requests and then we have this basic
pipeline and that's the next point we
get the ability to attach additional
behavior before and/or after each
request such as logging validation
caching authorization and so on so I'm
going to give you two examples in this
presentation one to automatically
validate every request that comes into
the system
and another to automatically log every
request that comes into the system so
let's have a look
the first point I want to make is using
CQRS to simplify our system design so if
we come to this application lay here you
can see and especially if you know
Northwind traders I've tried to clean it
up significantly really what I want to
see here is just feature folders and now
I have just this common folder and that
common folder contains all of the
infrastructure so we're going to look at
these but right now I want to focus on
these feature folders so there's
basically two features in this template
there's a to-do items list and there's
the existing weather forcast lists which
I've moved the logic from that from the
controller into the backend into that
application layer let's have a look at
the two items commands and crews so you
can see there that we have great clarity
just from the folder structure if we
want to modify the feature that gets to
to-do items file we know where to go
everything that we need to modify that
feature is in there
it's the same with create delete and
update so it's very easy to navigate you
can see here I have a create to-do item
command and it's responsibility is to
create a new to-do item you can see I've
got to create to-do item command
validator and that's because this is
partly a DTO for everything that we need
to create it to-do item and we need a
validator for that so the the behavior
so the responsibility of the validator
of course is to validate to create to do
it on command let's have a look at this
interesting num create to-do items file
so it's got a get to-do items file query
and oh my god bingo and
see it's dependencies right up the top
here it's dependent on I application
dbcontext which is an interface for
working with our DB context is dependent
on the mapper and the solutions using
Auto mapper now and it's dependent on
this I CSV file builder so you can see
it's dependencies are all on interfaces
there's actually no dependencies on
infrastructure even though what it's
doing is something very much related to
infrastructure if we come down here we
can see it's quite simple we grab the
records from the database we do a
projection which we'll look at shortly
we then call our infrastructure service
file builder to build it to do items
file we pass it the records we construct
a view model and we return that so
really when this request is made what
they'll get back is a view model so you
can see that we're really simplifying
the design and not only that because
we're moving away from domain services
in this implementation we actually have
a single file for each feature in our
system rather than our domain service
that has a collection of kind of related
features we just have a single file and
it's really easy to find it's really
easy to modify and it's really easy to
avoid breaking changes one of the things
that you may have noticed that I've done
here is that I've actually nested the
handler inside of the query and that
improves discoverability greatly when
you developers start working with this
solution they'll go to the to-do items
controller and they'll say I want to
look at this get to-do items this query
now if I had separate files it would be
easy for them to navigate to the query
but they wouldn't see the handle or I
want them to be able to see both so we
press f12 on that we go to the query we
can see the handler and it's just a nice
experience for them they don't kind of
have to even pick up the mouse to make
the changes that they need to make now
we talked about how we're using mediator
with the solution for our commands and
Cruz and you can see that here so we're
defining this get to-do items list query
as an I request a mediator I request and
it's going to return the type to do
items list via
so it's very simple to define that then
we have the request Handler and you can
see here it's a request handler for a
get to do items query which returns it
to do items list via so that's all of
the kind of plumbing we need to do to
define all of our commands and queries
as a request and with that we get some
really wonderful benefits so we
essentially get this pipeline where we
can add cross-cutting concerns so if you
have a look in here I've added three
cross-cutting concerns I've got a
request logger a request performance
behavior and a request validation
behavior let's look at the logger so the
logger is responsible for logging every
request that comes through the
application layer so every command and
query that comes through the application
layer will be logged it's using Donaire
cause built-in logger and it takes in an
I current user service and an I identity
service so this solutions using asp.net
core identity obviously I don't want a
dependency on identity in my core so
I've made an interface so that I can
have the implementation elsewhere you
can see it's quite simple essentially it
gets the name of the request it gets the
user ID from the current user service
and then it gets the user name from the
identity service and then it logs all of
that information out to add to the
dotnet core logger and depending on
which provider you have associated with
that is where the log will end up so
that's for every single request with a
single a single file now I also have
performance logger so this for
Qwest performance behavior is a little
bit different that the request logo was
just running before each request this
one runs during each request it's part
of the pipeline so we're injecting the
same services but essentially we start a
timer a system Diagnostics timer we wait
for the request to finish we get the
response we stop the timer and we're
saying if the elapsed milliseconds was
greater than 500 then we're going to log
a warning to the database so it's so a
similar kind of effect but it shows how
we can use a behavior to do something
before and/or after each request comes
through the pipeline and the last one
that I've got is the request validation
behavior but I better show you how
validation works first so I've got a
very simple validator here using fluent
validation now of course I could use
data annotations and they're great for
simple validation scenarios but they
don't work so well for complex
validation scenarios if I wanted to do
Crossfield validation or if I wanted to
interact with some service as part of
that I can do that effectively with
fluent validation this one is quite
simple it's basically saying that the
name property is a minimum a maximum
length of 200 and it shouldn't be empty
if we have a look at the Northwind
traders solution we've got a slightly
more complex validator you can see here
we've got kind of standard simple rules
but then down here we've got a rule for
the postal code we basically say when
the country is Australia and the postal
code the postal code must have four
digits and so if that fails we'll say
the Australian post codes must have four
digits and we've also got a rule for the
phone number so we say must have a
Queensland landline so we're coming down
here and we're actually looking at two
properties on on the model we're saying
that the phone all the facts must start
with us at our a7 or that will fail so
we can do complex more complex
validation including validation on child
collections as well and we can also
inject services with that we just have
to be careful of the scope for those
services
so coming back here we have these
validators and you can see how they're
associated with the command so basically
an abstract validator create create
to-do item command now if we come to the
request validation behavior then we just
have the single behavior to validate all
requests that are coming into the system
so you can see we essentially grab the
validation context we check to see if
there's any validators and if there's
any failures then we return a validation
exception later on when we look at the
front-end we'll see how that's actually
transit translated using a custom
exception bitl where to return that into
a more normalized response for an api
such as a bad request or are not found
those sorts of things okay next thing
that I wanted to show you is that I've
implemented something that I'm really
excited about and that's automap ah I
know not everyone's excited about
automata but I've done it in a way where
I think it's going to be a really great
experience and I think that I'm not
going to run into too many troubles so
the first thing that I did was to use
one of the new c-sharp eight features
which is a default implementation for an
interface so you can see here I have an
interface I'm at from type so I'm
essentially able to say I map from to-do
item in this example and I can add that
to my DTO and we'll have a look at that
and then I have this mapping method and
I've got a default implementation for
the interface and it basically says I'm
gonna create a map or map from to-do
item to to-do item DTO
and what that does is it creates just a
natural conventions based mapping for a
mapper so if this mapping is very
straightforward and it's conventions
based you won't need to do anything more
let's have a look at that in the door in
the context of a to-do item so
you can see this mapping is
straightforward it is convention base we
don't need to do anything else that's
now mapped is recognized by Auto mapper
and we can go ahead in our query and we
can just say project two and that's it
we can also do nested projections in the
same way if we have a look at a more
complex example on this one so you know
it's in employees so it in get employee
details it's actually not a convention
space mapping there is some handling we
have to do so all we had to do was
actually implement the interface so we
add the mapping by profile we create the
map and then we then we add any any
custom mappings that we'd like to have
so you can see here they're for member
ID on the on the on the DTO which is
right at the top here that's going to be
mapped from the employee ID and then you
can see down the bottom here that were
mapping a child collection so we've got
this collection of territories and we're
mapping it from employee territories so
if we go to the employee territory DTO
you can see it also implements eye map
from and it specifies the mapping
profile now we don't actually have to do
anything else because I've added a
little helper class to wire it all up
automatically for us because now I can
set and forget so you can see the
mapping profile will apply mappings from
assembly which is this method here and
it essentially scans the assembly to
find any types that implement I map from
and then it calls the mapping method it
calls the mapping method either from the
derive type if the mapping method has
been implemented or from the interface
if it hasn't been implemented and that's
it very simple so it's invoking method
mapping for each of those so we don't
have to we can just add my map from and
it's done to you
now there's one more thing that I've
done which is really important
for the workaround order mapper which is
to add some tests and the tests are
really simple and they're gonna kind of
help me with 80% of the issues I'm
likely to experience so you can see here
I've got the assert configuration as
valid and that will basically check the
mappings that I've created and make sure
that the properties in the DT OS
have been correctly mapped and then I
also have a list of the maps that I
expect to exist so I'm expecting there
to be a map from a to-do item to to a
to-do item DTO and to to-do item VM it's
my responsibility to put those in there
if I do forget and obviously I'm gonna
get a runtime error this is the first
place I'm gonna come I'm gonna add that
in and then I'll be protected in the
future so these two tests are just gonna
help in a big way I've found them to be
very useful and I'm not running into
many problems at all and as you can see
it's trivial for me to do projections
I'm not writing projections except in
the most complex of cases even with
nested projections so I'm very I'm very
happy with that result one of the other
things that I've done in until in many
of the layers is just to add a
dependency injection extension and so
you can see with this extension here
that were basically just configuring our
services so in our web project in
startup we just go services dot add
application because it's an extension
method and we're adding Auto mapper
mediator and those couple of behaviors
that we've created and that just cuts
down on the amount of code that's in
start-up dot see us when we're wiring up
dependencies in there so it provides a
nice clean approach and also means that
kind of add the dependency injection
that were handling in application layer
and infrastructure layer is actually in
the layers
so
see we've looked at the behaviors we've
got some customer exceptions so for
example in the let they see in their
to-do items if we try to get a to-do
item that doesn't exist it's rose
they're not found exception and then in
our custom middleware that we've got on
the front end it converts that into a
404 and returns that to the client we
have a lot of interfaces so you can see
there's an eye application dbcontext
will so we're trying to get good
separation of concerns from our
infrastructure project there we've got
our CSV file builder which will have a
look when we get to infrastructure our
current user service and how identity
service I think that covers everything
I'd like to cover in that layer so let's
go back okay so key points for the
application layer using CQRS plus
mediator simplifies your overall design
it gives us a single pipeline in which
we can implement a lot of the same
behaviors that we'd like to implement as
cross-cutting concerns fluent validation
is useful for all validation scenarios
yes we could use data annotations for
our simple validations but we can use
fluent validation for simple and complex
validation scenarios automap are
simplified our mapping and projections
and we've got some tests behind the
scenes to help back that up and keep
that working nicely and this is
application layer is independent of the
infrastructure and data access concerns
we've been very careful to use
interfaces and to keep the
implementations outside of this project
so next we're going to have a look at
the infrastructure layer so the
infrastructure layer contains our
persistence concerns how identity
concerns we're using asp.net core
identity it's both things related to the
file system perhaps the system clock and
API clients essentially anything
external now in this solution I've used
one project but there's nothing stopping
you for a particularly complex
infrastructure component creating a
second project and the way that I would
do that is call it infrastructure dot
say identity if I had a lot of
of identity work but for this solution
and for a lot of my solutions
I can I can actually get by with just
one project because we can separate
things by folders as well it's not
necessary always to create lots and lots
of projects so before we get into this
when we talk about persistence we often
talk about the unit of work and
repository patterns and I thought that
this was had been put to rest but then I
saw a big argument flare up on Twitter
the other day and some of the some of
the best people were just arguing you
know it's we should still be using the
repository pattern no we don't need it
it's not useful for anything so I want
to show a hands who thinks we should
implement these patterns okay about 20%
of the rounds who thinks we shouldn't
awesome so look the thing is it's not
always the best choice because if core
insulates your code from database
changes it didn't itself is an
abstraction the DB context acts as a
unit of work and the DB set acts as a
repository so if we're looking to get
the primary advantages from those two
patterns that is abstraction from our
database we don't need to do that
if core already does that for us in the
past we would always implement these
patterns because it was the only way we
could affect effectively test logic that
depended on these things but we don't
need to do that anymore because we have
tools such as e of court in memory to do
that for us but I'm not saying you
shouldn't use the unit of work in the
repository pattern just as I'm not
saying you shouldn't use the singleton
pattern I'm saying design patterns are
there to solve a problem all you need to
know is what problem you're trying to
solve and then implement the appropriate
design pattern so for example if you
were creating a repository because
you're only one repository at an
aggregate root and you didn't want
access to entities at lower levels such
as you wanted to provide your client
with access to order but not directly to
order details if they want to manage
order details then they go through their
repository that's a good reason to
implement that pattern
okay another reason why you might
implement the unit of work pattern in
the repository pattern is because you
wanted abstraction not from your
database but from entity
my core you want an abstraction from
your chosen ORM that's a good reason to
implement that pattern if that's
important to you for the system that
you're designing so it's a design
pattern use it to solve the problem that
you're having what did the experts thing
this is interesting so this is Jimmy
Bogart he's at this conference probably
not him my talk hopefully and he thinks
I'm over repositories and definitely
over abstracting your data layer so he's
against it and then we have Steve Smith
and he says no you don't need a
repository but there are many benefits
and you should consider it and he's
being diplomatic if you've heard Steve
talked about repositories he loves them
and I think if you went to him and said
hey Steve I'm thinking about not using a
repository for this he'll tell you why
you should and he has excellent reasons
for doing so and then we have John Smith
and he says no the repository slash unit
of work pattern isn't useful with EF
core so even the experts agree but I
think keep it simple
remember it's a design pattern it's
there to solve a problem just make sure
you know the problem that you're trying
to solve so let's have a look at the
infrastructure layer
have a mouse cursor again and its back
wonderful okay so you can see in the
infrastructure layer I've separated kind
of the features that are built into it
by files are sorry by folders so you can
see I have a files folder and that's
where I've put my CSV file builder along
with some maps we'll look at that I've
got my ant identity folder and those are
the things that I'm using that are
related to identity I have my
persistence folder which is where all of
my EF course topper stored and I have my
services folder which is just my
date/time service let's have a look at
the persistence folder first because I
want to come back to configuration
identities so I said you know we're not
going to use data annotations but we are
going to use fluent API configuration so
you can see here I've got a very simple
example where we're actually just saying
hey this name has a max length of 200
and it is required and all that's going
to do is construct instruct our on how
to map that to the relational database
if we're using a relational database
there's some more complex examples over
in the Northwind solution so if I bring
up Y the configurations there this one
that's not very complex this one so you
can see that we're configuring a lot
more properties most of it is relatively
simple
some of it is because of the schema that
was designed for energy frame sorry for
Northwind traders it's a little bit
non-standard but you can see that with
this fluent configuration we're keeping
it out of our domain and out of our
entities and there's actually a lot of
things that you can't do with data
annotations when it comes time to
configure in your R and so you have to
use plugin configuration anyway so why
not have it all in the same place now
when you when you're using those
configurations there's a handy little
method which you can use to apply all
configurations from your assembly and
you can see there it's just applied
configurations from assembly and we're
saying hey everything from disassembly
okay so one thing that I wanted to show
you in relation to the DB context that
I've created is the Save Changes method
it's actually responsible for
implementing the auditable entity
feature and it's on Save Changes so you
can see here is quite simple but you can
extend this example to be whatever it is
that you want if you want to track value
changes this is where you'll come to and
start to implement that so you can see
on Save Changes I think it basically
gets any entries that are implementing
auditable entity if the entity state is
added which means we're going to insert
it into the database it goes ahead and
sets the created by the use of idea for
who created this entity and it created
the date/time now so this is coming from
our service which is backed by an
infrastructure implementation same thing
for modified we grab the user ID assign
it to last modified by and the date time
now and assign it to last modified and
then we save our changes so that's a
very nice way to implement one point to
note here that could catch you out in in
the past when we overrode on model
creating we could actually leave out
this based on our model creating because
it in the.net core code it didn't
actually do anything well now it does
with with asp.net core identity if
you're using identity that line is
required and if you leave it out it will
break I
I'll show you some of the work that I've
been doing around identity sub viously
with the implementation of asp.net core
identity in this we want to be able to
access some of those identity services
in our application layer so I've
implemented a few you've seen get users
by get user name I think
being used in some of those behaviors
I've also implemented a create user a
sink and a delete user I think what's
important about this is not really what
it's doing it's the fact that we've
implemented this which is an application
layer interface and we can now use this
logic in our commands and queries so we
can continue to build this out we can
start to work with user roles and claims
and all that sort of thing we can even
separate this into a couple of services
whatever it is that our needs are but
this shows how you can get started doing
that it was one of the most requested
features for Northwind traders was just
to see kind of that identity experience
and how that would flow through to that
application layer and how users could
interact with it something that I have
to do commonly on projects is to
generate CSV files and in the past I
would use file helpers it's a great tool
but unfortunately I couldn't get it to
work nicely within this solution
architecture because we have to decorate
our DT OS with a lot of attributes or so
related to the creation of a CSV file so
I found a new tool which is very popular
tool called CSV helper and the wonderful
thing about this is it allows us to
create file maps inside of our
infrastructure to define how these
things will be implemented within the
CSV file so we have this DTO
which belongs to the application layer
and we have this map which will define
how it's going to end up in the CSV file
so with that implementation it's very
clean we can just build a CSV file
builder which I still have to make
generic and we can basically take in a
bunch of records from an application
layer write it out to CSV it'll it'll
use the maps and then return the memory
stream so if you remember we were using
that in this query and then we're
returning the results back to
the client so the dependency injection
and this one is sorry an infrastructure
is interesting to just a little bit just
because I've passed over the
configuration and the web host
environment
okay so I've passed that over from
startup and so that allows me to just
configure this this layer with with a
few more options so you can see I'm at
in the DB context and so grabbing the
connection string but I'm also looking
at the environment to see how I should
configure identity server there's a lot
of tests associated with this project
and now that we're using identity server
we've have to have authenticated tests
and so if it's in the test environment
we add a test client and you can see
we're basically enabling the resource
owner flow and we add a test user so
that makes our testing very easy if it's
not then we just are wiring up these
services we don't worry up the date time
service the identity service or the CSV
file builder service in tests we have
just mocks that we're using for that
because there's only so much we want to
test so the important thing and I think
I've made this point is that no layers
should depend on infrastructure and and
that can be a little bit confusing at
first but we have to remember that
infrastructure is there just to provide
an implementation now having said that
the web project does have a dependency
on infrastructure that's for dependency
injection only so we should only see the
reference to infrastructure in the
startup dot CS so if you see it outside
of startup don't see us in a controller
you know that's a red flag hopefully
you'll pick that up as part of a code
review now you can implement more
complex behavior such as assembly
scanning to wire up your dependency
injection but I find that to be a little
bit over the top we have code reviews we
have pull requests so I tend to pick
those things up
all right so key points there
infrastructure is independent of the
database I didn't actually show that let
me just show that quickly so we know and
love energy framework or at least a lot
of us so you can see that with energy
framework or we have these providers so
you can see we find it there we go else
is gone again
sequel server so it's that provider
reference that allows us to remain
independent of the database so energy
framework core is one big abstraction
and we use providers to define which
database we'll be interacting with we
can switch that out for Postgres and the
solution will still work we just have to
rebuild our migrations okay so we prefer
to use fluent API configuration over
data annotations we can do more with
fluent API configuration we provoke
conventions over configuration so I
didn't touch on that but that's an
important point
when you're working with these
convention based frameworks such as Auto
mapper and such as EF core it's really
important to know the convention so take
the time to learn them that just means
reading the documentation because these
conventions allow us to write less code
and allow us to write code that's
simpler easier to understand but if you
don't know the conventions then you're
going to end up writing things that you
don't need to okay so it's important so
we automatically apply all entity type
configurations in our DB contacts using
a little helper method and we can know
that no layers depend on the
infrastructure layer for example the
presentation layer we want to keep that
logic out and within the core of our
solution so next we're going to have a
look at the presentation layer so in the
presentation layer is basically our
client we could be we can have a
sparkline this one's angular can be a
web api razor pages MVC web forms blazer
whatever we want it's it's not going to
be too hard to change our front-end now
because we have a really nicely defined
core it's dealing with really
well-defined view models and so all of
our logics inside of there and not in
the front end
let's have a look Mouse yes great so the
first thing that I want to touch on is
that controllers should not contain any
logic and we're gonna have a look at the
history of the Northwind products
controller for that so you can see this
products controller in the beginning was
a very typical example of how we build
controllers would go ahead and inject
the context we would return entities and
we had lots of logic in there and the
reason that we had logic logic in there
was because there was nowhere else to
put it we had taken a very high-level
concepts such as the controller on the
outer edges of our application and
injected something that was in the
lowest levels of our application the DB
context where else are we going to put
our logic so there's kind of a trap
right from the beginning of course we
know returning entities from the
controller was just asking for trouble
circular references security issues all
those things so this wasn't a very good
state okay so let's
look we very quickly did an update and
we were working with commands and
queries at this point and you might
think well that's not much of a changes
well you probably think actually that's
crazy James look at all those things
being injected but it was still good we
can see what this controller depended on
in order to operate sure that's their
never noticed that before my god I've
got a look that's weird
it's not being used never noticed it all
right but regardless they have our
queries and our commands they're being
injected and our our actions have become
simple they're trivial we're also
returning GTRs without returning
entities anymore and look they've become
one or maximum two lines of code so just
that change just implementing CQRS has
made this solution so much simpler and
that's why I say yeah we love CQRS it's
all about performance and simplicity and
scalability but really for me its
simplicity and this is this is a
reflection of that so much switched over
to look at the to do items controller in
clean architecture now because it's
reflective of where we're kind of at now
okay so the two items controller is very
simple let go there we go so you can see
it's actually implementing a base API
controller so that's something that's in
this solution and it's responsibility at
the moment is just basically to decorate
with the API controller a default route
and then to inject mediator by property
injection so you can see here it just
essentially requests the mediator
service so then we know we don't need to
do that for each controller so you can
see here in to get all method we're
basically just sending a mediator
request so queries and commands are
requests and everything goes through the
mediator pipeline so you can see how
simple things have become and that's it
that's how we're building these today
and that's how you build it if you
in this solution so you can also see
that for each of the queries I'm taking
the time to create well-defined view
models and what I want is for my client
to request something such as a to-do
item and to receive everything that they
need to render that view I don't want
them to make additional API calls to
receive more information
I want that view to be very well defined
and provide everything the client needs
and by the same way I also want to be
able to test that view you know if a
buttons meant to be disabled I want to
be able to test the view to see if the
button should be disabled so I can have
properties like allow create and that on
the front-end that can be a silly
binding just to a button but on the
backend that allows me to write a unit
test to see how the how the view is
going to respond and so we're even
encapsulating that kind of logic inside
of core now one of my absolute favorite
things with this solution is the open
API integration so we might launch this
solution so we can have a look at that
so from the web UI project all we have
to do is go dot net run now I've
currently got it configured so that it
starts the angular so angular CLI server
at the same time I've got a blog the
last blog post I did was at NDC Sydney
last year and there's a blog post that
tells you all about that behavior and
why you might want to disable it so it
might be worth checking out so when we
start this it's going to launch the
backend Web API and it's going to launch
the front-end angular client while
that's happening I want to show you a
couple of pieces you can see in WWE
I've got a specification file now that's
being automatically generated by n swag
who's heard of n swag awesome
almost 50% of the room so n swag is an
open API tool chain it allows you to
generate open API specifications and it
also allows you to generate clients
based off those specifications so I have
n swag actually generating the
specification here and putting it into
the WWE root for
now using that I'm able to generate an
angular client for my front-end and if I
come in here into app into here you can
see the client so this is a typescript
client for interacting with this API and
so I don't have to write this code
anymore and what's more all of those
well defined view models that I worked
so hard to create
including the DT OS are also generated
for me so when I go to interact with my
API from the front end if I have a look
at say my to do component all I actually
have to do is inject the client that I
want to work with and start working with
it so you can see this is me getting all
of the to-do items this is me creating a
new to-do item I didn't write any of
that code I didn't write this view model
on the client it's all being generated
from the backend so with something like
an swag we're actually bridging the gap
between the back end and the front end
the source of truth remains our back end
it remains the core and we generate what
we need for the front end and what's
more when it changes I have n swag
automatically rebuilding all of that so
if you have a look in the web UI and you
can see here I've got two references and
so I goes peanut core and an swag
msbuild msbuild with n swag actually has
this task so when I build the web UI
project
it runs an swag and an swag will pick up
a configuration file that I've generated
and it will build a new specification
and put it in WWE route and we'll build
a new typescript client and put it in my
angular app and I'm good to go
like it's set and forget so not only do
we have ensberg sorry open API bridging
the gap between the front end in the
back end we've also created an
automation process with ends work where
we never have to look at it again unless
it breaks it does sometimes but that's
okay
we can fix it
so let's have a look at that
configuration I've done a little bit
further so there's our inspired
configuration I didn't have to build
that myself because ensberg has a studio
which is very good at building
configurations unfortunately it's only
for Windows but I understand a lot of
Mac users have Windows on the flip side
so that's okay
let's see okay so we've got our
application running now so that's the
angular but we don't want to go to the
angular one we want to go to the asp.net
core one because it's being hosted by
kestrel all right now so what's that do
that time hey Stevie
let's just let's let it handle it then
oh good thank you JK okay so you can see
this is the sample app and you can see
it's got the basic things in the
template also my last to-do list so get
things done it's going to ask me to log
in which is great I'll go ahead and log
in there's my to-do list I
you might notice on the entity that I
defined the key instead of being an int
I've defined it as a long because I feel
like I have so much to do that to
billions gonna be a little bit of a
limitation so let's get started so I can
add items I can delete items and I can
mark them as complete and remember when
I showed you the code behind that that
client was all generated all the details
were all generated and so that's the
kind of experience and this is what
we're using for real projects as well
now behind the scenes we have that open
API happening right within swag
we also are exposing swagger UI and
we've we've provided a mechanism which
you can supply the bearer token so that
we can try out those offender
request so for those of you don't know
swagger UI is really great it reads the
specification it generates an interface
and allows us to learn about the API and
it also allows us to interact with the
API so it's great if you learn in a new
API and it's also great for your
developers who need to test something
out so you see here there's all about
different actions that are available our
operations that are available for our
to-do items and here's our weather
forecast
I better grab a token so it so that I
can show you how that works
so if I grab that tea paste that in I'm
gonna get a token by going that start I
have a look at a network request token
it'll be here so you know with this
template that Microsoft's provided that
integrates identity we don't have to do
as much work they've really I think it
was mostly Dominic and Brock who
contributed to this identity servers
built in and behind the scenes in in the
angular implementation the services
there's interceptors there's guards
everything we basically need to get
started anyway I want to grab this token
so I can show you making our authentic
ated requests so I'll grab that I click
authorize I can paste that in and I just
need to trim off that first part so we
need everything including bearer and
onwards to click authorize you just hide
that and now we can make requests so we
go try it out execute and we get back
our results and that's good and we can
do that like we can create items we can
delete items we can update items it's
it's a really useful tool and and you
can see here you know it's not it's not
a backdoor by any means we still have to
be off then okay do we still have to
pass through a token but it does allow
us to troubleshoot and debug and learn
about the API which is wonderful so I
promise to show you the exception
middleware so let me show you that now
there we go
so it's very simple something -
something definitely to build on so I've
got a customer exception middleware down
the bottom I have an extension for I
application builder so if in within
startup ICS we just go use custom
exception handler I'll show you that
really quickly there you go
so just like that so that wise it in and
then up the top here you can see
essentially any requests that come
through we'll look at them if they're an
exception we'll figure out what type of
exception they are if it's a validation
exception will change it to a bad
request or some people like to use and
processable entity we can do that to
whatever suits our needs if it's a not
firm or change it to a not found and
we'll provide some information the the
validation exception actually uses this
failures property and what I'm doing
there is just taking all of those fluent
validation errors and putting it into a
format that's just like model States so
if you used to programming against model
state on your front-end I want to
provide the same experience or whatever
code you've got now we'll continue to
work with that I should show you the
current user service because it's it's
very simple but it is an important part
of the story so for an authenticated
user we just grabbed a claim name
identifier and that's the user ID so we
can use that when we're trying to find
out more about the user such as their
roles and that sort of thing I pass it
into the identity service where I'm
getting the user name and that sort of
thing so pretty simple one thing that
I've neglected to show a little bit are
the tests
I'll probably just show you the web UI
tests they're really great so I've got
tests for the controller and this is a
test for the create method and so you
can see here that I've got a method that
I've created which is factory get
authenticated client which gets an
authenticated client so that I don't
have to deal with that it's got a test
user behind the scenes and we can
actually then test requests against the
API and these tests are really powerful
we can test a lot when we test against
the API layer because it's an exercise
of the stack so when you write these
tests you can see they're really simple
to ride but but they have a big payoff
I've also got tests for infrastructure
so you can see I've got some application
dbcontext tests to test my orders for
entity behaviors so you can see how that
works and in the domain and application
layer i have tests that will work with
the commands in queries including
providing a an in-memory DB context so
that you can write very effective tests
and they're quite simple to write to so
if you have a look at this one we can
test the create to-do items command we
don't have to deal with the context
because that's provided by the base
class it's all injected for us and we
can write very simple tests so that was
a big goal for me was to be able to
write really effective tests not have to
for each project wire up all of the
authentication needs all of the
in-memory needs just be able to use this
project and get started so key points
controllers should not contain any
application logic that logic is not easy
to use to reuse we want that outside
sorry inside of our core we should
create and consume while to find view
models we don't want our clients to
think too much for themselves just
provide them everything they need and
let them render the view open API
bridges the gap between the front end
and back end
you saw how we've done that we're
generating clients and we're generating
DT owes and makes our life very easy
code that we would have had to have
written ourself in the past and n swag
in this case is automating the
generation of open API specification and
the clients that we need we didn't see
it here today but you can also generate
c-sharp clients fetch clients is a great
lot of options that you can use within
this tool so next steps so if you like
what you saw today then you might want
to install the solution template so to
do that all you have to do is run net
new install clean architecture solution
template and then you can create a new
solution by running net new
see a hyper - SLN so clean architecture
solution so I demonstrate that for you
really quickly so from our command
window we go net new install clean
architecture solution template just like
that so this is backed by a new get
package I updated at last night at about
midnight and I've dated again at about
9:00 a.m. I'm updated again at about
12:00 midday I've been working on it a
lot but you can see here we now have
this short name the clean architecture
solution and see a solution so if we
want to create a new project let's make
a directory NDC's Sydney 2019 okay and
then we can go dotnet you see a solution
clean architecture solution it will
generate that and everything that you've
seen here today will be ready for you to
use and correctly named spaced based on
the directory that you created it in so
if we come in here we can see we've got
an NDC Sydney solution we've got our
layers ready to use all of our tests
including an infrastructure associated
with those tests ready to use and it's
all namespace as I said - based on you
know the folder name that you specified
so you're basically ready to just get
underway so thank you very much for
attending my talk today I hope you've
liked what you saw if you did be sure to
install the template also check out the
repository this was only made possible
through the contributions of thousands
of people around the world so I'm hoping
that we can see the same sort of effort
with the clean architecture template
don't be afraid to ask the tough
questions sometimes I get stumped I'm
still learning but in the end we we end
up with a better solution thank you
[Applause]